hey guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
um i have a theory about dating in 2021
and i want to see if you guys what you
guys think of this because
i think it explains a lot that i've seen
in my lifetime
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe
i'm trying to get to 15 000 subscribers
as you know
and yeah this is gonna be my first piece
of original content
um you know i'm a reaction type of girl
anyways okay so i made this scale
okay men i could not get this one to
switch for some reason
but this is women and men and basically
this is like
how many options they have in the dating
marketplace
so i like to do scale of one
two five because i think that people are
more honest
in scales of one to five like i think
like a six
is really like a three in a like a one
to ten scale
to one to five does that make sense okay
but so what i've learned in my mana
sphere time is that
eighty percent of the or twenty percent
of men get 80
of the women so that's men right
and they have access to
um let's do a square here they have
access to the five
board threes and twos they give all of
these women
attention but they really only want to
date
um would you guys say the fives
fives and fours we'll get fives and
fours so
they'll be hooking up with these guys
but these guys will be hooking up with
these girls too
and these girls too but these are the
only ones that get the relationship
status right at some point right
this could be like you know at first
they hook up with all of them and wife
one maybe some of them are cheaters
whatever
so this is what i think caused that i
hate men
like feminist women
that i actually i don't even need these
headphones do i this is what caused the
i hate men like feminist women because
these girls ended up getting cheated on
right they have the fours and the fives
that everyone wants a lot of these girls
end up getting cheated on
boom they become feminist i hate men's
these girls have been strung along by
the fours and the fives
some of them knowing some of them not
knowing um
and they're like pissed off because
these guys treated them like trash so
all of these women have like a really
warped view
of the world like they just think men
are trash men are trash what i found is
that like
exceptionally unattractive girls and
like unattractive guys just like find
each other
like they're just i don't know they're
like
left out of this mess like what i've
seen is that the most unattractive women
or not
the most unhappy women in dating are not
the most
unattractive what it is is it's the
twos and threes or fours fives and sixes
because they've gotten like a taste
of like these guys they've gotten like
how do i put it like they
basically have been like i don't want to
say screwed over because like women make
their own decisions
but they feel screwed over by these guys
because they thought at the end of this
if they just
slept with them or did whatever they
would get a relationship out of it they
didn't
these girls that got a relationship
didn't even have the men to be faithful
now i know women are promiscuous i'm
just telling you
from the woman's point of view like what
i've seen i know you guys have seen oh
and then at the same time
the okay look we're gonna go over here
the guys that are undesirables let's
hope this is red
so these guys right here have been
strung along
by actually let's even undo that because
what i found is that the men that are
the most unhappy are the threes and the
twos
so
they become and i'll tell you why
because they sound like they have
nothing to offer they have some stuff to
offer
and the girls that they feel like are on
their level right
are not aware that they're on their
level so they're here
chasing the chip what do you guys call
them chads brads
but really they're getting nothing in
return
and so these guys are saying look it
i'll give you a good life i'll give you
this i'll give you that
and these women are saying no you're
beneath me basically
so then this i wish i could have like a
little anger emoji
but like this infuriates these guys
makes them so mad because they get
nothing pretty much and
i'm trying to think about what else i
would add into this
three three two two okay and then so
then as soon as the girl has been
played right by enough
of the brads whatever she says you know
what i'm gonna make a different decision
and maybe date someone that wants to
date me so then
after they've been ran through or
whatever
by the fours and the fives they say you
know what you are on my level
and unfortunately a lot of these guys
just accept it
i know you guys are saying like oh you
don't have to accept it you don't have
to
but clearly like it doesn't seem like
they have other options
um and yeah so what i found
is that the twos and the threes or
fourths fives and sixes
on the woman's scale they're the least
happy and the ones i've actually found
that ugly people
kind of know where they're at so they
just like date each other and they're
like fine
but i've seen the most unhappiness and
the twos and the threes
and like both men and women but for
different reasons
anyways this is just like my two cents
let me know if you guys agree with me or
you disagree just a theory i have
um i think that's really all i got
i will talk to you guys next time also
i'm not
discounting the experience of men or
saying like
women don't do the shitty things too
they absolutely do
but that's just what i've seen from the
experience of a girl
anyways talk to you guys next time